Chicago you're up next November 11th and
the 12th Grand Rapids December 9th and
the 10th get your tickets to those shows
on my website at ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it in the night
pants Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media if you are watching this
show on YouTube thank you very much
please hit that subscribe button like I
say it means the world to us it's a big
help and it's free it's free and if you
gotta have more then you gotta check out
the patreon we're going on well over 100
episodes now I've been telling y'all it
is five dollars a month there's no other
levels you sign up for a year you get a
month free and it's the Honeydew with
y'all and I highlight the low lights
with you all and you all have the
wildest [ __ ] stories
I I've ever [ __ ] heard all right it
blows my mind every [ __ ] week all
right so if you or someone you know has
that story it's got to be heard please
submit it to honeydew podcast gmail.com
we'll hopefully get you on and do an
episode together all right the tour
continues uh Chicago I will see you guys
November 11th and 12th in Grand Rapids
December 9th and the 10th all right
y'all that's the business right there
you guys know we do here we highlight
the low lights I always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers very
excited to have this guest on this week
first time here on the Honeydew ladies
and Gentlemen please welcome Eddie Bravo
welcome to the Honeydew Eddie bro uh
thank you for having me dude thank you
for being here
am I close enough to the mic yeah come
on up and get in with okay
um before we get into anything please uh
plug promote everything you'd like all
of it uh me and Sam Tripoli we do a show
called tin foil hat comedy we tour
around uh the United States we got um
Fresno coming up Colusa Casino coming up
that's in the first weekend of December
and then we're trying to set up uh
Denver and Salt Lake City that's in the
works right now that'll be sometime in
November uh if you're interested in Jiu
Jitsu 10th Planet
jj.com that's uh where you can find all
my Jiu Jitsu information and
oh and I gotta I have a podcast on Rock
thin it's called look into it with Eddie
Bravo I got about 23 episodes uh the
first eight are free and uh it's it's
behind a paywall but I'm only interested
in doing
podcasts for people that uh
um want to support me you know what I
mean if you don't want to support me
then that's fine I don't need
I don't need your attention you know I
want to save uh my energy for people
that really want to hear what uh is on
my mind and if you don't if it's too
crazy ignore me
that's it great but we do give our free
episodes though after you know the first
eight are free and then from not nine
through 23 you know rockfin is awesome
it's like the uh the Netflix for
podcasts you pay I don't know what it is
nine bucks and you get everybody oh is
that right yeah you get everybody oh
yeah yeah it's awesome man it's awesome
there's so many great podcasts and then
you get a you get them all
just like Netflix but for podcasts well
look I I've been following you for a
while through comedians like tripley and
those guys that I know and I've been a
fan of yours so I appreciate you coming
on and I at first just met you recently
um officially at Tripoli show yeah you
blew me away man you blew me away You're
you I was like who the [ __ ] is that dude
I never I've never seen you do uh stand
up man I never even heard of you and uh
I inquired my damn Ryan sickler okay and
then I went backstage and we started
rapping exchanged numbers and boom here
we are here we are yeah you actually
said you went out there and watched me
and I was like oh [ __ ] I was waiting
right yeah dude thank you that made me
feel good
um so look I want to talk to you about
your life I mean I don't know anything
about you so let's start at the
beginning
um where are you from originally here in
Southern California born in East L.A
actually but
um
was raised in Orange County Santa Ana
that's where they put all the Mexicans
he said put them that's right yeah yeah
they didn't know what to do with them
because all the white people from L.A
they left uh they left La South to
Orange County that's the new spot uh too
many Mexicans uh were infiltrating La so
the white people said let's go to Orange
County they took off they went you know
Laguna Niguel Newport Beach Costa Mesa
they're like oh [ __ ] this is awesome but
they needed to bring some Mexicans to
clean the goddamn houses you know so and
cut the grass and build [ __ ] so they
designated Santa Ana
as the
the servants uh the workers wow all
right I hear you yeah yeah that's like
where you all live you can clean and
work here but you can't live here yeah
you're gonna live in Santa you're gonna
live in Santa Ana it's still Orange
County you could tell people you live in
Orange County
you don't have to get all detailed you
just say Orange County
you benefit from it so tell them Santa
Ana though there would be some white
people that lived on the edge of Santa
Ana that'd be worth my family
the northern edge of Santa Ana
definitely
bordered a white city Tustin in Orange
Tustin and Orange I know The Jewelry
Exchange in Tustin white cities backed I
mean those are good cities hilarious but
Santa Ana the part the part of Santa Ana
that bordered those nice city we had a
few blocks in Santa Ana so your male
said Santa Ana you lived in a nice house
and it was it was like damn you live in
Tustin those people didn't even know on
their mail it said Santa Ana they said
[ __ ] that [ __ ] this is Tustin dog I live
in Orange they would lie yeah yeah
because technically they kind of did
because it you could tell it didn't
belong you know
um so do you have brothers and sisters I
have an older brother a younger sister
uh
you know so three of you and then your
parents were they together growing up
did they split ah
the neighborhood I grew up in
uh was mostly single moms with their
kids one by one all the husbands left on
our block just one by one oh yeah
and all the kids
that was one couple that stayed together
to the end they were like the king and
queen of the block
Macario and Socorro Galvan both of them
man they were like the the king and
queen of that that street and we had a
church dude we had a church we'd live by
a church
big ass Church Our Lady of Pilar and um
so one by one except for Macario and
Socorro except for them
everybody got divorced nobody made it
and then mom's all stayed the monster
like we'll go do yeah the moms never
left the mom stayed dad's left and then
you know all the kids that we were all
just like wild little Mexican kids into
hard rock and heavy metal so you had a
lot of kids in that in your neighborhood
at the same age and everything no not
exactly that was I was part of the
younger crew
um I was at my brother was four years
older than I mean he had his crew like
if I was 10 he was 14 big difference
between tennis you're right about that
so my brother there was like you know a
few 14 year olds and there was only like
two or three ten-year-olds and um and
then there was like some 18 year olds
they really didn't hang out with us that
much and then the 22 year olds you know
who lived in the back in the back shed
right you know what I mean they got
divorced too so there was a bunch of
levels I was part of the younger
everybody
and then it ends up we end up just like
playing playing football on the streets
and we're just monitoring whose mom uh
is dating whose mom has a new boyfriend
oh and what kind of car yeah
look at your mom's boyfriend's car look
at your mom's boyfriend then you just
talk [ __ ]
my best friend [ __ ] got a Fiero
yeah what's the last time you saw Fiera
did it in my best friend's mom dated
this [ __ ] you know cause every now and
then my mom was kind of hot so she she
even dated like a dude from the
California Angels back when they're like
Juan Benitez my mom dated that really
yeah my mom was a little hottie so when
she when she when um my stepdad finally
left and and left her alone with three
kids to raise that was my stepdad but
that was my older brother like we'll
come back to that I got you because I
want it I want you to explain it it's
complicated all right my like my mom and
dad stepdad a lot of weird [ __ ] but um
not weird typical actually but
my my friend's mom dad she scored she
got a boyfriend that drove like a big
ass truck driver and he was all a
Mexican guy but like Americanized kinda
uh born in Mexico but been out out here
for like 15 years got a good job truck
driver and he was all about Peterbilt
like it was just you know he was just
like Peterbilt belt buckles so he had
like a decent car like he had a Camaro
or some [ __ ] like oh [ __ ]
Matt's mom's coming up to be like oh
[ __ ] and he was like so proud
that his mom got uh a boyfriend with a
job
that's really for him too
because he never had a dad just like me
my dad was always gone too everybody's
dad was gone so his dad was gone
everybody dealt with it in different
ways but he loved his
mom's new boyfriend so much he started
he wore he got a Peter
he had like Peterbilt uh like toy trucks
and [ __ ] he was all about it did he was
so proud
he's like oh peterbilt's the best so
every time we're going to go to
Peterbilt oh that's a kenworld yeah and
then he left her
he stole he started taking it you all
should have worn Peterbilt your
Peterbilt
shirts down man
chose a lot of that [ __ ]
all right so let's go back for a second
your your biological father he okay so
he's around for how long
okay so my mom 18 is dating uh see I
said my mom was fine even though we were
all poor Grandma her mom and dad my
grandma and grandpa had 10 kids she was
the second oldest ten kids dog my
grandma was having kids and my uh my mom
when my mom was having kids I got ants
that are the same age I got an aunts
like my sister she's a year older than
that I got a an app that's two years old
you call her aunt though yeah but we're
like sisters we grew up together we were
like like best friends growing up and um
um and as I got older they were always
trying to get me laid they're always
hooking up with their friends like we
got another one for you Edgar we got
another one so they're like take
pictures of like like my uh pictures of
me and show them to girls at work and
then try to they're always trying to
hook me up it was awesome that's great
my aunts were the hookups dude they
loved it they enjoyed getting me girls
but anyways
um my mom is 18 she starts dating this
uh Porsche mechanic Mexican Porsche
mechanic that's my stepdad okay like
Newport Beach the best mechanic at
Newport Beach so my mom was you know we
were poor but she was fine all right I'm
not gonna deny that
um she she nabs a dude like a dude that
is making great money
top Porsche mechanic in Newport Beach
but he's an [ __ ] and he's a wife
beater and he's a [ __ ] um
yeah yeah just a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
right so he uh gets her pregnant
uh my grandma and grandpa hate him they
everyone hates him because he's just a
dick and uh uh she she has my brother
Alfonso her his name is Alfonso Bravo my
stepdad's last name is Bravo that's
where I get Bravo his name is Alfonso
Bravo my mom says Maria and they end up
getting married she gets pregnant nobody
in the family likes him he's a dick uh
when my sons or my brothers two they get
a divorce she beats he beats the [ __ ]
out of her wife beat her so now she's
back at my grandma's with my brother
just now she's got a she's a a single
mother uh and then my mom always wanted
to be a singer she always sings with
Mariachis anytime you see Mariachis my
mom gonna get there and start singing it
my mom always wanted to be a singer no
matter what even if you're at a
restaurant and they show up she'll
figure out a way to get it it used to
embarrass me when I was like 12.
no Mom not the mom like this oh my god
oh I'm all pissed off but then I learned
to love it I was just I was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm probably still an [ __ ]
now but I was an [ __ ] when I was a
kid just
and and uh maybe had something to do
with this story but anyways so now my
mom's going out she's living with her
mom and dad with my grandma and grandpa
with all the kids and now she's part of
him I'm on like the party well she's
still only like 20 21. she's like a
party my mom went partying and she's 70.
she's just a party she's the party
starter she's always dancing and always
wanting to sing she's just
um
and uh
uh she goes to a club in Santa Ana and
the club promoter my dad he's a club
promoter for Mexican bands he'd bring in
Mexican bands like he was friends with
Vicente Fernandez okay my dad was
bringing Mexican bands into Santa Ana
and into downtown L.A so when he was
down in Santa Ana bringing Mexican bands
for all the Mexicans down there my mom
went to the show
he married five kids no promoter married
five kids you truck driver during the
day delivered industrial size uh like
condiments 200 restaurants that he
drives not quite a semi not Peterbilt it
was one like a bobtail like in between I
don't know it wasn't Peterbilt but it
was Essie rykoff it was like they're all
over La the green they're green trucks I
still see them but that's what he worked
for during the day but at night he was a
club promoter he meets my mom
and he's like he's married five kids he
needs my mom and he's like oh [ __ ] I
gotta get this one VIP so he just like
takes her to VIP and he's like you know
falls in love with her uh
tells my mom that he's gonna divorce his
wife he got five kids
and um she's like you know okay he's
like super charismatic she's super
charismatic everybody love my dad like
he got in with my my uh Grandpa my mom's
dad and they were just like you know he
was like 13 years older than my mom so
he'd hang out with with uh her dad
they'd be like doing tequila shots
playing cards all night you know what I
mean and so they got along great he
might now all of a sudden my grandpa
hates her first husband Alfonso Bravo
but loves my dad Pedro Cano Kano is
actually my real last name okay but I
was forced to use my stepdad's last name
so um
uh so now my this my dad gets my mom an
apartment in downtown L.A right there
off Hoover and Olympic it's still there
that apartment complex is still there
it's crazy [ __ ] I lived there till I was
three and I I thought mine I had
memories of it I'm like I wonder if my
memories are right then when I was like
28 I went back there boom I found the
spot I'm like oh my God I remembered
exactly it wasn't even a dream it's
exactly the way I was three it was weird
but anyway so my dad now gets my mom an
apartment in downtown L.A from Santa Ana
she has a two-year-old a two or three
year old son my brother's about two or
three
he still is married with five kids he
gets my mom pregnant
he's trying to get a divorce but uh
uh his wife wouldn't divorce him she
felt like she was gonna she was super
religious and thought like she's gonna
go to hell she got a divorce so she
wouldn't Grant him a divorce so he
decided to torture her and say hey I get
told her all about my mom his mistress
that he's seeing Oh and announce that
I'm gonna be gone for a while my my
mistress uh got pregnant and I'm gonna
have a son that was me so if my dad was
evil my dad was he he was telling his
wife about the affair he was having with
my mom you know and my mom the whole
time was thinking he was going to
divorce her and they're in love now
she's young she's like 22 or something
at this point and uh but it got to the
point where
he wasn't he wasn't getting a divorce he
was like kind of digging having
uh you know
both Best of Both Worlds right
so my mom it didn't work out
um now do you do you remember him at all
coming around you said you lived there
for real three yeah yeah I do remember I
remember walking in on him taking a piss
and and you know you know there's
everyone's got a story like that when
you walk in on your dad taking a piss
and his dick just seems like tremendous
as a matter of fact like like a couple
weeks ago for the first time my son's
10. and then for the first time he
caught me running like out of the shower
naked and he was just I could tell he's
shot and I was thinking I go is this his
moment when did the first time he saw
his dad's dick he'll be telling us later
for sure
I just remember my my dad was standing
like this the door was open and he's
like this and he looked over
I'm like what the [ __ ] is that
so uh it didn't work out they took my
between my mom and my uh real dad so now
she's got two kids two sons four years
apart and she goes back to Orange County
back to Santa Ana but he's got six kids
now yeah so does he just bail on you and
your mom all together and just stay with
that family or do you does he exactly so
we she goes back it didn't work out
between them and now first husband's
tracking her down found out about this
new [ __ ] she's been he's trying to he's
he wants her back
so um
she now my mom is back at my grandma's
house
uh she's got two sons now and we're
living at my grandma's um at this point
three four
um he was around he was doing both
families until I was like two or three
he was doing it for a while and um my
mom and they still like him even though
he wasn't given the divorce
your your grandparents remember you said
they liked him but they didn't like
stepdad and they still like him my
grandpa and my dad they just got along
you know what I mean uh
it's a common problem for Mexican men
you know managing uh multiple families
you know that's not uncommon you got a
family in Mexico you got a family you
sneak across the border that's what my
my grandfather didn't think about that
my family here family there yeah yeah my
grandma and grandpa Story how they how
they cross the border that's another
story but
um now my mom is back at my grandma's
house
Grandpa and Grandma's house and uh I'm
like three or four my brother's like
seven
and um they get back together again
first husband Alfonso Bravo the dick and
my mom's wife hater wife being they
start dating each other again and I I
really don't notice I'm at my grandma's
and I'm hanging out with my aunt
Sterling my sister whether or it's I'm
having a great time
um and uh
then original
husband gets mom pregnant again
this is your sister this is my sister so
now I'm in the middle I got an older
brother and a younger sister interesting
so they got the same dad I was just wow
I was uh the bastard child yeah in the
middle there yeah so now but wait were
they married again when he got your mom
pregnant with your sister that's where
it gets [ __ ]
is once she got pregnant again they
decided to try to make it work again
so now
I'm five now when they decided to make
it work again so now from between the
ages of five and ten I lived with my
stepdad the shitty okay and if she's
still that way is he still a piece of
[ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah he's a piece of
[ __ ] uh but he he left when I turned 10
he beat my mom up one last time and then
bailed to Mexico
and uh but you know I'll never forget
that um there was a lot of crazy [ __ ]
that happened during um
did you ever have a physical altercation
with them
dude I mean you had at some point start
feeling your own strength and he made a
lot of money he was uh like I said yeah
uh not tall he was like probably five
seven five six but he did lift weights
and he was stock he was in the lifting
weights Porsche mechanic
um
um had some white friends you know what
I mean he was blowing up
you gotta wait for him he would be
tripping down
so um
so be from the ages of five to ten
I'm living with my stepdad and I'm
forced to use the name Bravo okay that's
cool because my mom was like she don't
want nobody to know she didn't want
she's like you're [ __ ] Bravo now so
and back then they didn't keep records
that well because my birth certificate
says Edgar Alberto Cano there's no Bravo
in it all
but with that birth certificate Edgar
Alberto Connell my Social Security says
Edgar Bravo my mom just went when we
signed up to school she just put your
Bravo Now bang she goes Nobody needs to
know [ __ ] and I'm like damn I hate this
[ __ ] and I gotta use his name
damn [ __ ] this [ __ ] I hate it
and it as a kid Bravo is a is a shitty
name because anytime
people kids are so stupid
um in what they think is funny and like
they said Bravo
you know it's like yeah I'm like dude
that's that's so not funny but it was
annoying as [ __ ] uh out in at the first
day of school is really the only time
the teacher would call out your name
because after that she'd you'd have a
seating assignment she would take role
and she would just look at your [ __ ] she
wouldn't call anybody's name out but
that first day she's gonna call your
name out and I was so self-conscious of
Bravo I'm like what a dumb [ __ ] name
I want to change my name I
um I transferred myself to a white
school and used my without my mom's
knowledge and use my original name I'm
gonna [ __ ] this I'm not gonna use this
[ __ ] Bravo name and I
transferred myself to a a white Junior
High yeah and then when my mom found out
she never went to no [ __ ] PTA
meetings or not she didn't give a [ __ ]
she never went to my school once but
when she found out I'm at a new school
my last name is Kano not Bravo my mom
she grabbed me by the [ __ ] ear dude
and dragged me like a case man
she went inside that school she could
show me where this [ __ ] school is we
went to the white side of town almost in
Tustin and Orange how'd you even get
away with that my aunt lived in the in
uh and um
in the area that District so I use my
aunts
um address and then I just signed
everything I just forged everything
because when you when you sign your
mom's name when you ditch class and you
have to have a doctor's note or yeah
it's [ __ ] it's the same [ __ ] though
we can go to court you want to go to
court it's the same one but anyways when
my mom found out she dragged me to
school she [ __ ] kicked down the
principles obviously
then she goes
where are you [ __ ] files dogs you'll
pull the we gotta change his [ __ ]
name right now he's not Kano he's Bravo
and I'm like oh my God how embarrassing
my mom freaked out so she let you stay
at the school though you just had to
have the last name yeah but I had to
keep Bravo
um let me ask you this question I know
we're going to jump ahead for just a
moment here when
did you finally accept Bravo when did
you Embrace Bravo when did it feel good
I hated it so much but my step my real
dad you know he didn't he didn't really
give a [ __ ] anyway I'm like how could
you not give a [ __ ] about I I would see
him like once once um a year and he'd
come by and show up to my school give me
a hundred dollar bill in front of all my
my friends at school like I'm in
like uh second grade I got a hundred
dollar bill so he would do that and he
was only in town to bang my mom
he just wanted to hang out with my mom
yeah so he would show up he'd go get all
you you guys won't you want to go to the
movies I go hell yeah I want to go to
the movies you want to go see Shogun
Assassin you want all your friends to go
too oh yeah go get all your friends so
you'd get all his friends
and um
all right I even get all my way to get
all my friends and he'd pay for
everybody we got a movie see Shogun
Assassin
and meanwhile hanging on my mom you know
you take us all to Disneyland and he's
just so he could hang out with my mom he
was uh you know he didn't give a [ __ ]
about me and I was like damn you know
what as long as long as he's like paying
for all this [ __ ] going to movies I'm
like [ __ ] it I don't give a [ __ ] he
ain't like I was like yeah you ain't
[ __ ] but you want to give me some [ __ ]
you can give me some [ __ ] I'll take it
yeah yeah you want to give him I went to
uh his truck I went to work with him one
day and we did a truck delivery all the
way down to San Diego and back did that
once he showed me oh there's my son oh
only time we did that and he'd come by
every now and then
um yeah but
how did he feel about you being Bravo he
didn't give a [ __ ] he never even brought
it up he didn't even bring it up but the
day Bravo
um left uh the family me and my brother
we coming back from a Boy Scout trip
where there was like Mexican boy scouts
man and um we went to like Joshua tree
and [ __ ] and when we got back she was
beat up when I we're in our Boy Scout
uniforms like what happened
she and she she explained to us what
happened and her hair's all [ __ ] up
black guy she's all [ __ ] man he beat her
up he dragged her out it dragged her by
the hair to the front yard and um they
called the cops they arrested him and
everything he got arrested but me and my
brother that was his real dad and my
brother my brother didn't like him right
and that was his real biological and
your sister when uh when
our mom was telling us this
we were like holy [ __ ]
so he's not coming back at all
I'm gonna be like oh [ __ ] like a hungry
and she goes yeah I'm like oh Mom love
you Mom oh you need anything and then me
and my brother walk down the hallway
yeah you got in our room dude we were
jumping on our [ __ ] bed in super
slow-mo dude
foreign
beat you guys or is he just taking it on
your mom and what was he a drinker what
was his thing he drank and uh he's he
smoked weed and um
he was he uh I could understand what
he's coming from a little bit though you
know what I mean I wasn't this real kid
and he had to support me
like uh
I I get it you know I get it a little
bit you know uh he I never called him
five years between the ages of five and
ten never called him dad he never called
me son never said we never but he was he
would do stupid [ __ ] like I just wanted
to get to school in the morning so I'd
wake up early my brother was always
waking up late he's always like I want
to get the [ __ ] out I want to go to my
grandma's house on the way to school and
watch him [ __ ] Land of the Lost yes
sick sick but in the sea monsters and
then I go to school so I got all about
that go up early go to my grandma's eat
cereal there because it's on the way to
school my grandma's house she lived
right down the street
um so
uh I'd be up and he was up and and he
didn't just beat me for anything like if
I did something [ __ ] up he would [ __ ]
me up okay but I was scared of death of
him but like if we were eaten just like
this he would just do this to me and I'd
be eating my cereal and he'd just stare
at me he was just staring me wouldn't
even just you wouldn't be eaten he would
just just
stare a hole through me and then I'd get
up and the kitchen's over here and
here's the doorway and he would get up
and block it he would oh yeah so then I
would go out the front door all the way
around the side of the house through the
back door just to put my [ __ ] uh
Fruit Loops Bowl away you know what I
mean it was like that so it was like
that like he was like that he wasn't
like just beating the [ __ ] out of me but
he was just a lot of mental [ __ ] yeah
and
one day uh me and my brother used to
steal NFL pencils from the department
store and then sell them for 10 cents at
school we used to hustle you know what
do you need Cincinnati Bengals boom here
you go 10 cents bam we we used to make
some extra cash you know and
one day but we used to steal the pencils
yeah of course we stealing any money we
steal them and then you sell them at
school
so one day me and my brother you know we
um we we need to uh
restock our inventory and we were at a
department store newberries in Santa Ana
and uh he gets caught I didn't get
caught he got caucus we're not going in
together we go separate right we're just
Pam he gets caught I [ __ ] leave the
storm like oh [ __ ] he's [ __ ] busted
oh damn damn he's busted they took him
upstairs to the office where they you
know where they talked to you and then
and I didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on I'm waiting outside the store
going [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what's gonna happen
[ __ ] my stepdad's gonna [ __ ] us oh now
we gave him a reason he just he needed a
reason yeah I'm like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm
waiting out there and it's getting late
and then a guy comes down and goes you
you uh are you with Alfonso Bravo and
I'm like yeah he goes his parents
already picked him up like oh
[ __ ]
so I run up dude I run home dude I'm
running home [ __ ] full clip
I'm like what's gonna happen what's
gonna happen
is he gonna throw me under the bus is he
gonna [ __ ] it so dude I can't I get
to the house oh my God I look in the
living room and I hear them wait all
there's there's like a living room when
you walk in and then you you make a
right and then there's a long hallway
and our room is at the end and then
there's a room in between and then
another hallway so there's like all the
doors were open so I could see all the
way down the hallway so I walked into
the living room and I went oh [ __ ] my
brother was like without a shirt like
this against the wall
and my stepdad do you remember that
scene that you remember that scene and
The Shining where
there's like some old like some weird
shits going on and they're gonna I don't
know who it is because someone's going
through the hallway and they open the
door and there's like a man like sucking
like some
furries dick and then he goes like that
and like it just it was like that it's
like scary [ __ ] he's whipping my brother
whipping him yeah
and
he looks like that he goes oh God damn
he looked at me like this is gonna be
fun
so he could like he's thinking dude he
just got done whipping his own son yeah
like a slave you're gonna get that
actually my brother dude he was made fun
of at school and PE when he had to take
off his shirt dude he had it was that
bad he [ __ ] whipped the [ __ ] out of
him so he as soon as he sees me he does
that I was like oh man
this is it's like [ __ ] Christmas for
him
first time ever my mom [ __ ] jumped in
between us he just went to grab me and
I'm like oh [ __ ] my Mom jumped like
[ __ ] Big John McCarthy dude she
jumped in front of some [ __ ] pulled
us apart because nah and he didn't even
fight it because he knew it's like she's
doing me a favor because I'll probably
kill him and go to jail
film my stepdad because my mom said no
[ __ ] way after what you did to your
own son you're gonna kill this mother
you will yeah so apparently uh my my
brother told him that we both did it so
he just couldn't wait to whip my ass but
my mom [ __ ] snapped in [ __ ] blocked
and then she whooped my ass
I was like crying instantly but good
yeah
[Music]
so uh yeah that that was
that was scary
and he didn't pursue it he under he
understood
that uh what that meant my mom just
[ __ ] saving my life so he splits and
then what we're wild on the streets me
and my brother yeah
my mom every day she said
[ __ ] late 20s early 30s early 30s
early 30s and uh she was all about I
will never get married
attack and she never did never got
married almost one guy never got married
and would always talk about it and then
one guy almost got her to [ __ ]
reconsider Nico Nico gotta he was like
[ __ ] so now me and my my I'm like 13
and my brother is 17. and we haven't had
a dad it's just my mom and us and we're
on the streets we're [ __ ] thieving
we're trying to [ __ ]
we're trying to just hustle and survive
my mom didn't have any money she made
150 a week trying to support three kids
doing what what was she doing she did
like
electronic stuff like you know an
assembly line putting Electronics
together and [ __ ] like that she worked
hard she worked hard and she loved over
time if she can get to work on Saturday
oh she loved that [ __ ] oh man and then
on Fridays every God damn Friday when
she got home from work 5 30 we're going
to McDonald's dog we're going to
McDonald's that was just Heaven yeah it
was just like McDonald's was was
everything to us this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp life can be
overwhelming and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation feeling
helpless or trapped Detachment fatigue
and more I know I get run down I don't
feel like doing anything I don't feel
like talking to anyone I don't feel like
going anywhere we associate burnout with
work but that's not the only cause in
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out and better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself talk talking with
someone can help you figure out what's
causing stress in your life you know I'm
a big believer in therapy I think
everyone should be out there talking to
somebody looking for some answers
getting a little bit of help all right
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with the therapist
under 48 Hours the Honeydew listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com Honeydew that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew for 10 off
your first month cooler weather makes it
easy to miss signs of dehydration like
overheating or perspiration which means
it's even more important to keep your
body hydrated every day I start my day
off with liquid IV try to get one in the
middle of the day too we keep them here
at the studio all the guests use them
Kirsten we all use them over here one
one stick of liquid IV and 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster and
more efficiently than water alone it
contains five essential vitamins B3 B5
B6 B12 and vitamin C and with three
times the electrolytes of traditional
sports drinks it's made with premium
ingredients grab your liquid IV and bulk
nationwide at Costco or get fifteen
percent off when you go to liquid iv.com
and use code honeydew it checkout that's
fifteen percent off of anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code honeydew at
liquid iv.com again that's promo code
honeydew at liquid
iv.com do it today y'all stay hydrated
crowd Health puts your health care back
in your hands cut out the middle man
save money and fund your health care
costs without relying on big government
or big insurance companies let's be
honest the insurance model was broken
crowd Health has a better way to fund
your health care cost pay one low
monthly total to fund your account your
monthly subscription helps fund health
care cost of the entire crowd Health
Community you can see any doctor you
want there are no deductibles exclusions
or co-pays only pay the first five
hundred dollars of any health care event
the crowd Health Community takes care of
the rest crowd Health puts the community
back in Community Health Care take
charge of your health care today with
crowd Health open enrollment is the only
time you can hit eject on the broken
system without penalty so don't wait and
for a limited time join for just ninety
nine dollars per month for your first
six months when you use promo code
honeydew at join crowdhealth.com that's
join crowdhealth.com promo code honeydew
crowd health is not health insurance
it's a totally different way of paying
for health care term and can conditions
May apply now
get back to the do so what's happening
to you getting in trouble you're getting
locked up are you staying out of trouble
like are you just getting by just enough
I never
I never got locked up as
um as a teenager
well well no no but really I've only
been uh arrested and put in jail once
and that was just for like 10 hours
I got it's a long story that's another
story uh but uh I didn't do anything
wrong I had a gun on me but uh I was
working and I could I used to manage a
chain of check cashing stores oh man
yeah yeah you're crazy yeah yeah that's
scary as [ __ ] I had a friend that was a
bail bondsman and these people used to
come in like that [ __ ] and I'd be like
they're all wow yeah during the riots
dude I almost got killed during the riot
damn dude yeah the riots man so
man I don't even I mean there's just so
much to uh uh basically through
throughout all that [ __ ]
um
once my stepdad was gone me and my
brother were wild on the streets we're
wild on the streets and then you know
we're on the Rock and metal and uh
I wanted to be a rock star or a football
player that's it that's all it was
football player a rock star and
as a uh the football
um bug got into me uh like when I was
eight you know nine when the Rams uh
went to the Super Bowl against the
Pittsburgh Steelers I was a Steelers fan
at first just because they were so
popular
and uh I'm I drew a picture of the Super
Bowl like like I can't draw worth the
[ __ ] but I drew stick figures and I was
so proud of it of like you know a pastor
Lynn Swann cotton and you know uh do you
remember that Super Bowl yeah I think it
was Vince Ferragamo was playing
quarterback for the Rams uh but anyways
um and then my brother four years older
than me and just like
uh a large percentage of siblings the
older brother sometimes uh
gets off on uh humiliating a sibling you
know what I mean and he liked doing that
you know my brother liked doing that he
he loves me to death and he's Pro he's
proved to me that he loves me but he
also made me cry and he awesome uh made
me pray um
to God that you know that he would die
and [ __ ] like that you know I'd be like
oh please kill him
please kill him God God kill him
I would pray to God to have my brother
killed uh he would embarrass me he's
like you know we're a bunch of [ __ ]
kids on the street and I'm like on the
uh I'm hanging with the youngest uh of
the crew and he's older so they like to
make fun they're like making fun of the
young kids but um I played peewee
football at nine when I was nine years
old
um I had a friend who uh
at uh parents both parents together on
the other side of town and they uh we
became friends and they paid for my
football so all of a sudden I'm in like
Peewee and we're playing tackle it's
weird because
peewee football is like your third
fourth and fifth grade and you're
playing with [ __ ] helmet and shoulder
pads and everything but when you get
into junior high sixth seventh and
eighth now it's Flag Football it's not
Taco football and Junior High out here
so
um when I played tackle football
everybody's same size everybody same
size at nine you don't start really
separating until you're like 11 12 13.
that's when you start you know you start
figuring out who's the short guys and
who the who the big guys are so at nine
[ __ ] I was playing a defensive lineman
and middle linebacker
so you get delusion them yeah you know
you get delusion like [ __ ] like I felt
like and I was pretty good at nine I was
going after my I loved football
and uh
so I thought okay I'm gonna be a
football player or a rock star it's
going to be one of them whichever one
comes first instrument or are you gonna
sing or ah in the beginning I was
playing drums because nobody on the
Block wanted to play drums and I'm like
okay I guess I'll [ __ ] play drums we
need a band so it was more about drawing
I didn't want to be a Sim my voice sucks
um I know I knew I couldn't be a lead
singer or anything like that I do I do
background vocals and [ __ ] I'll do like
a line here and there in the music I
produce because I never stop producing
music I was about to put on album out
real soon oh yeah
but um uh back then it was just like I
saw a Kiss Meets the Phantom of the park
on NBC at eight I saw that Chevrolet and
I saw all those fans screaming for them
I got I want people screaming for me
like that you know what I mean and uh so
I want to either a rock star football
player so when I get into
sixth grade
sixth grade is where uh uh everything
started to change
um
I got the first Junior High I went to uh
was mostly um like you know at Junior
High you had a claim a gang you don't
have to be in the gang you don't have to
gang bang you don't have to kill nobody
but you have to clean you have to claim
when we're on our block everybody's
listening to Rush kiss
Def Leppard we're listening to like Ozzy
Van Halen the police but when you go to
school you got to pretend like you got
you got to dress the part there's like
gang banger clothes and on your peachy
folder you better write either middle
side or F true one of them
and what were you guys supposed to and I
and I either F Troop or middle side I
didn't I didn't want it I didn't want to
do it I'm like I'm gonna claim no gang
my brother said just [ __ ] do it
because my brother had to clean metal
side you got to know the sign and
everything boom boom you know and but he
wasn't a gang banger as soon as he got
he would go to school in like cholo weed
shirts or like um I don't know if you
don't know but they're like gray and
black stripes across like this they have
brown ones and they have black and gray
ones I think they're called weeds shirts
but um uh cholos and gang bangers where
my brother used to wear he wasn't in a
gang but he would claim it and if he had
to fight my brother could fight he would
but he just we just want to get back to
our block where we could be ourselves
right you know uh and I didn't want to
play that part so it was weird because
in elementary you don't have to claim no
gang but now it's sixth grade I'm like
[ __ ] that I was dressing like a surfer
ish with lightning bolt shirts Ocean
Pacific remember that ocean
yeah that's what I would wear and
uh the gang bangers at the school
um would uh uh like man
why you acting white you Mexican man you
messing like black guys would tell me
that [ __ ] too and I'm like no I'm just I
just I'm just a me you know and uh
like I said I had two ants that were
older than me so now I'm in sixth grade
I have an aunt that's in seventh grade
and a half that's an eighth grade and
they're they're all out they're all
playing the game they're not so loud
[Music]
that's real [ __ ] oh hilarious that's a
real [ __ ]
I thought you're gonna say your age like
she's doing he said seventh grade
hahaha
so I'm in sixth grade
Daddy's in seventh Alice is an eighth
and Patty and Aunt Alice yeah and
they're super popular beautiful but
they're dressing like a chola they play
the game they crease their their chords
and they're dressing like Charles at
school but they're not gang bangers but
you gotta claim it it's kind of like a
fashion almost they just you just go
with it it's fashion you know no one
will [ __ ] with you and
uh because
Patty and Alice were so popular at that
school like their girlfriends like oh
look at their nephew look at Edgar the
little they're the Patty's nephew oh so
the seventh grade girls are they thought
like oh you know so I started dating a
seventh grader I'm a sixth grader it's a
big deal dude seventh grade chicks never
date sixth grade dudes that just doesn't
happen but since Pat my ants are so
popular they thought it was a way to get
to closer to them
so I'm dating this girl named Sabrina
um and uh and I'm a sixth grade
and meanwhile
I trial for the [ __ ] flag football
team and they cut me like right away
like immediately they cut me they go
this [ __ ] way too slow I didn't
realize how slow I was like damn and I
tried out in Vans everyone you know yeah
yeah I was running with a 40-yard dash
in bands and I was slow as [ __ ] I had
good hands and I had moves dude I could
Juke a [ __ ] I just have no speed
no explosion I'm gonna make you miss but
if you just turn around and not give up
I'm not outrunning nobody they're not
even I'm not outrunning girl girls are
faster than me everybody's faster than
me but I can catch dog I got good hands
just slow as [ __ ] but um
so they cut me I'm like oh [ __ ] so I
spun it in my own head that y'alls are
[ __ ] you guys are playing flag
football I don't do that [ __ ] I play
tackle I just did a peewee football dog
so that's how I saw it I'm like yeah
wait till we get to high school ninth
grade and I'm gonna show you what's up
once the helmet comes on I saw the pets
[ __ ] okay keep playing this [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] flag football that's how I saw
it so I I put okay football gonna be on
hold until I get to high school because
it's [ __ ] so I break up with Sabrina
for a sixth grader Margaret
Sabrina loses her [ __ ] no [ __ ] sixth
grader gonna break up with me you're
lucky I even dated your stupid ass I
only dated you because your [ __ ] Aunt
you know so she's pissed
who's got science class with me
that's so good so now she's like sends
goons to [ __ ] [ __ ] with me and beat my
ass now there was a [ __ ] hit on me in
sixth grade my oh [ __ ] first the guys
couldn't wait to have a reason to [ __ ]
me up because I'm I'm a Mexican guy
dressed in in Ocean Pacific shirts and
I'd have like a like a mini ghetto
blaster with only one speaker I couldn't
afford the one with it
but the one with the one you could buy a
gem coat you know what I mean that's
like 18 bucks so I would but I would
still have it on my shoulder I'd be
walking during recess I would just go
out in the fields and just be listening
to Ozzy and Judas priests and [ __ ] and
they hated me oh they're like this guy
is is uh not playing the game so once I
broke up with Sabrina and these guys
took me behind the [ __ ] PE building
were about to [ __ ] me up I start crying
and [ __ ] and um they felt sorry for me
you know uh uh
because I just [ __ ] like I wasn't
gonna fight that there was like seven of
them and they wanted to beat me the [ __ ]
up and I just started crying so much
they just left me alone and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I gotta transfer myself to another
school
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here dude I
got to get out of here so I had an aunt
that lived in this one school at the
edge of Santa Ana by Tustin in Orange
it's still Santa Ana called Willard
intermediate and they either they had a
lot of white people and Mexicans they
were whitewashed right no ganks there's
no gangs at this school I gotta get
through that [ __ ] school for seventh
grade so I use my aunts
um address and I fill out all the
paperwork all I do is tell my mom go mom
next next year I'm gonna go to a great
school it's all the way by Dustin she
goes okay she was like she thought it
was great news and that's all she didn't
say do I need to sign anything she
didn't she's got a she's got her job to
worry about
so then she freaked out when she found
out I'm a Kano I'm Edgar Cano at this
new school she freaks out busts down the
principal's door gets all the paperwork
in order embarrasses the [ __ ] out of me
but now I'm at this new school and now
I'm at a score I'm no [ __ ] friends
dude I went from being like uh
um like too [ __ ] popular in sixth
grade to now nobody knows me I have one
friend there from first grade Lee Mays
like Jeff Spicoli you know Jeff Spicoli
yeah from Fast Times of course he was
Jeff spicola okay long hair he had
cropped up on top Super Metal dude it's
it's like
1983 84 at this and he's super Jeff
Spicoli Surfer metal dude half Indian
half Mexican and but he never comes to
school so when he's not there I gotta
sit at lunch and at recess like by
myself because everyone's got their own
clicks and I'm not gonna go up to the
click and go hey I'm the new kid
um
too much pride and I was a big [ __ ] it
was just too like dude what am I gonna
say I'm gonna so I just sat by myself
and that's
that hurts so much man sitting by your
[ __ ] self and then everyone everybody
knows who the loner is everybody knows
they don't have no friends but when Lee
would [ __ ] just show him to school
and not smoke weed today and just show
up to school like on a responsible human
being so I could have someone I just
need someone to sit next to me and
everything's cool whenever he got when
he whenever he did go to school Lee
Mains he would just said sit next to me
I felt great I'm like we're talking
we're just bullshitting about [ __ ]
you know Black Sabbath you know kiss
we're just talking battle and [ __ ] I'm
like [ __ ] thank God he's here because
during Squad I don't get you know no one
gives a [ __ ] you're just sitting at a at
a desk that you that was assigned to you
and you know nobody knows who what The
Loner is but at lunch they know who
those loner is they they get everybody
out of the school and you're in the
lunch area
and they'll only let people in it to to
go to use the restroom inside so I
always use the lead and show up lemays
didn't show up I'm using the [ __ ]
restroom and I'm gonna take a long ass
[ __ ] you know I'm gonna kill as much
time I'll just be sitting there and
there was no internet there's no phone
you just sit there dude you just sit
there look at my folders I'm just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] killing as much time as
possible because it's excruciating
sitting by yourself at lunch it's
[ __ ] excrucia everyone's having a
good time they're on their clicks and uh
and that after second period every day
is when they they hang up the list of
people that that didn't make it to the
school and I'd always check that should
I go up to the list I'm like
[ __ ] he's not here God damn it you
[ __ ] you would know yeah so I would
know go God damn it you know and then
um I'm just a total [ __ ] loan
everybody knows it and it's excruciating
I just need lemays there as long as he's
there and then in junior high every
Junior High got one girl who just
developed her titties quick every Junior
High got one Angel bade big Double D's
and then there's one that has full C's
Denise Rosen she had full seas and then
everyone else no titties remember that
nobody nobody
yeah nobody had titties in junior high
it might be different now with all the
hormones that they're putting in the in
the milk but back then only one girl had
boobs two girls double D Angel babe
Double D's Angel babe and she was pretty
too so she's the most sought after girl
in uh the school and the most popular
guy in school is a half white half
Samoan named Donovan mauga
Superstar totally whitewashed half white
half Samoan but where's all the latest
preppy clothes super athlete fastest guy
in school uh second fastest him in Royal
wilbon uh like there's two black guys in
that school and they were fully
whitewashed Royal will bond was [ __ ]
insane fast but Donovan Model guy he was
like he was just the coolest
[ __ ] guy in in school and um
he was uh
making moves on Angel Bay he was falling
in love with Angel babe he's making some
moves and um
Lee [ __ ] maze was making moves on
Angel Bates when he when he was barely
there yeah but they had a class together
and now Lee Mays is making moves on
Angel Bay Angel Bay kind of thought
League maze was kind of cute
and Donovan malga found out
Donovan I swear to God
this is all true this is Middle School
again Junior High we're in seventh grade
now middle school middle we're all in
seven
[Music]
was making moves on her
heat during recess
he went up to him took him down mounted
him I didn't even know what the mount
was I just said dude he sat on his chest
and just beat the [ __ ] while I was
standing there like a Christmas story
just [ __ ] whale Donovan terrified he
was terrifying number one athlete and
now he's sitting on my only friend's
chest and just raining like dude it was
like
Smith and Scott Morris UFC 2. it was
brutal opened up his face he was [ __ ]
up and everyone's just cheering on him
by the time the principal got through
[ __ ] they pulled them both off
and
um
and I just stood there I didn't do [ __ ]
I was just they're terrified of Donovan
Malik this guy was what am I gonna do
you're gonna get beat too
that's what you get for [ __ ] what a
angel babe dog you were gonna go with
Angel Bay what are you thinking
and
um
after school I finally after they let uh
lemays out
he came out and I was talking in front
of the school and he had dude he had
like a Motley Crew those Aviator shades
on long hair dude he looked he could
have been an abandoned seventh grade
long hair it was all cropped up and he
had these big rock star glasses on but
you could see on like he had the he was
trying to cover it yeah all the [ __ ]
scar like dude he ripped his face apart
he was all [ __ ] up and he's just
standing there I'm like
[Music]
what's gonna happen you know the worst
possible news ever he can give me the
worst [ __ ] possible news it's like my
mom's gonna transfer me to another
school I'm like no no
we can work this out we can make this
good again
come on dog nobody let me talk to your
mom
we can't do this no it did he goes no
man I gotta I go
[Laughter]
no dude we can make this good for a
girl's big titties [ __ ] boy crazy
now he's transferred now he's gone my
only friend so now it's [ __ ] dead dog
lunches it's excluded it's a nightmare
I'm like living in a Twilight Zone when
it's not that's my worst that's my least
favorite part of my life
um of my life
so
during that I mean that's the least
favorite part that back then being alone
yeah and everyone knowing you're alone
in front of everybody it forget about
like you know a kid at that age doesn't
know what's going on in the world has no
perspective there's people in Liberia
like kids that like are eating hearts
and [ __ ] and like killing people and
seeing insane stuff
but as a kid you don't know that [ __ ]
you're just in your little it to me that
was hell yeah I was in hell and
meanwhile I tried out for the football
team there too Donovan Maga star dude
they cut me even quicker
you already cut dog you might as well
just go home right now
so but I told her you know what I told
all my friends back at the neighborhood
I told them that I made the team
as second string quarterback I didn't
want to get too crazy I thought yeah I
made it second string but they they
kicked me off the team because I got in
a fight
just made it all up made it up I
couldn't face my friends on the Block
they were still going to the other
school the gang bangers score right
right I said yeah I made the team but
God damn it they caught me because I got
in a fight I was second string
quarterback Don
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
so now I'm dude I'm such a loser dude
I'm a loser in seventh grade at Willard
and I'm I'm such a loser I had to lie to
all my friends and my brother everybody
my family I made the team but they
caught me because I got in a fight oh
you told your family I told everybody
that everybody
uh so now Lee Mays is [ __ ] gone
Donovan malga is like with Angel babe
now you see him walking around and [ __ ]
Donna Angel babe so and I'm like the
biggest loser ever everybody knows not
like I don't have a friend now everyone
knew that like that was my only friend
and then in drama I took drama
uh I just want like the easiest learn a
lot about yeah so in drama I start like
making friends with Nicole Anaya
cheerleader hot
and in drama we're like there's one time
where we're like all supposed to get in
a circle and hold hands and I'm holding
hands there my hands are sweaty as [ __ ]
her hands are sweaty I'm like oh my God
I can't believe I'm holding hands with
Nicole or not she's like cheerleader and
she her ex-boyfriend in sixth grade
[Music]
they broke up now he's with Angel bade
so I'm like thinking oh [ __ ] he used to
go out with Donovan she goes yeah but
that was last year I'm like oh [ __ ]
oh I guess you know that was last year
and uh he's got Angel babe now hmm okay
so then we just
little by little she became my
girlfriend and nobody knew and I would
walk her home
he's super popular
I'm the biggest loser of the school and
I'm secretly dating
like top three girls in school
and uh
I thought okay Donovan like I was like
in the back of my head I'm like you how
could he get mad he's with Angel Ben how
could he get man but when we started
just holding hands at school and walking
her to class and everyone was just like
I'm walking down the hallway
more comfortable
holding her hand and she's proud she's
like into it too she's like I'm dating
the biggest loser in the school and and
I don't give a [ __ ] she had she had a
lot of Courage she was Brave
[Laughter]
[Music]
I could feel the stairs walking around
school people were like what the f what
what is going on nobody can and it was
such a surprise to everybody that
Donovan malga it dropped his stock the
fact that she was dating me
so he couldn't take it he couldn't take
it so he was like he felt like the only
thing he could do is kick my ass
so he started telling everybody that he
was gonna [ __ ] me up and dude I was
Gerald five people were coming I'll
never forget Greg ales and
dude I just to let you know man uh
Donovan is planning on [ __ ] you up
just letting you know and I was like
thinking about what he did to lemays I'm
like oh my God oh my God donver Maga is
gonna [ __ ] kill me it's your three
o'clock right here oh dude he's right
and you know when it's coming or is I
don't know when it's coming anymore
I was like please just do it this
Saturday
people just kept saying Donovan's gonna
[ __ ] you up so he had people getting my
hair Donovan told me to tell he's gonna
[ __ ] you up I'm like oh my God oh my God
and I'm
uh in seventh grade in English class we
had this assignment to write a letter to
ourselves that we're going to read after
we graduate high school okay so we write
out like what's going on in our lives
today in seventh grade and then our put
you know self-addressed envelopes send
it to my grandma's house you put an
address that you know is probably going
to be there when you graduate and then
they send you the letter and then you
read you're like 18 years old and you're
reading some [ __ ] you wrote when you
were 14. that's cool so in that matter
dude
I was like
I don't know when it's gonna happen but
it's gonna happen for sure I'm just
waiting for him to do it I'm terrified
dude I wrote it all out it was like a
diary of like with truth
and then um
one day I'm in the bathroom and I'm
taking a leak
and
I zip up my pants and I turn around as
I'm about to walk out the bathroom
Donovan and his best friend Jaime they
both walk in and we pass each other and
I'm walking out of the bathroom and then
walking in and right there I just
stopped I said let's get this [ __ ]
over with all right no one's around I
went back into the bathroom just looked
in the mirror so there's like a mirror
that's like it goes down diagonal like
that and then behind you were the the
stall so they're pissing and facing that
way
and I'm you know you're walking I'm just
combing I'm just watching them take a
piss I'm looking at their backs boom and
they're like heinies like I was like
and then
foreign
to get [ __ ] just Sucker Punch just
combing my hair going let's just get
this over this perfect in here no one's
gonna see [ __ ] boom and I'm calling I
just didn't want to have it done in
front of my girlfriend you know what I
mean I go that that's hard to come back
from yeah
um so then they just walked out of the
bathroom and left and I'm just sitting
there combing my hair
what the [ __ ] happened turns out Angel
Bay found out Donovan malga was mad
because his ex-girlfriend was was uh
going out with me now she's like why
would you be mad wanna [ __ ] him up she
goes if you [ __ ] him up we're done ah
Angel babe saved my life [ __ ] yeah she
saved my life said you leave him alone
or we're done
oh dude she saved my goddamn life and
then after that uh I got accepted and
you know little by the eighth grade was
great what was high school like
you're an athlete in high school did you
go back to football yes I went back did
you make it
and yes okay all right
but everybody
makes it okay you don't get cut in high
school I got it so dude I made it they
didn't know what to do with me I made it
all they could think of is like I'm slow
as [ __ ] like a little back or something
no no no no no no no no
no you gotta understand uh you said you
had good hands I had good hands but I
was super slow and small
and small so all they could think of is
putting me as a backup wide receiver
and they never played me because I swear
to God in ninth grade at Santa Ana High
we had the greatest freshman football
team of all time it I I put that
freshman football team against any all
those guys for some reason all those
ninth graders could have played varsity
but they didn't they just kept them as
freshmen because they were true freshmen
they could all play Varsity right they
were fully
like Royal will bond he was the the wide
receiver from the black guy who uh was
at Willard and seventh grade him and
Donovan milega were the stars Royal
wilbon when he touched the ball nobody
could touch him he was so fast he was so
quick at every game every game was like
55 to nothing they were all blowouts
everything was just a complete Massacre
a blowout and I was Royal will bonds
backup
[Music]
yeah yeah but they put me in for one
[ __ ] play like during during the
season they put me in for one play but
my rival was a wide receiver on the
other side he was the other backup wide
receiver they put both the backups in
and he wanted so the play was to me just
five and out to the sideline
so he was [ __ ] jealous that it was
coming to me like he was pissed off
because this is the only time we're
coming in and uh he lined up offsides or
whatever but I did I did catch a ball
and gain like two yards and it went out
of bounds and [ __ ] and that was it and
uh but the play got called back because
he was lined up uh like in the neutral
zone or whatever something like that
um some kind of motion or some [ __ ]
and that was it and then the last game
of the season
halftime against Santa Ana Valley
halftime was 15 to nothing we're
destroying them there's only one half
left in the game in the season just one
half so at halftime the coaches said hey
we're gonna let all the because that was
a bunch of Scrubs like me they never
played ever we were just dude I had
Jersey game dad be walking around High
School 88 dog it was 88 and when no one
you know what I mean like I never played
but I had that Jersey and I could walk
around with it because I was on the team
um broke as [ __ ] I had cleats that
didn't fit oh they were too small and
after every football practice I would be
by the pool the high school pool just
with dipping my feet and uh and the pool
dude the cleats are too small and
they're a plastic and [ __ ] they're like
the worst because they were like 13
bucks bought them at a liquor store
and
uh so the last game they said we're
gonna let that dude they were gonna let
all the scrubs start offense and defense
for this whole second half I get to
start wide receiver and
a defensive back then we're just gonna
let us play we were up so much by
halftime like 50 something or nothing
so I was gonna get to play the whole
[ __ ] get the whole second half so
opening kickoff in the second half we
kick it to them and we're all running
going after I'm the last [ __ ]
that right and the first guy wraps a
dude's legs up second he's still
standing and then another guy just flies
like [ __ ] Superfly snucker and uh
just hits him on top the dude with the
ball braces himself with his arm and
Pops his elbow off so he's laying there
and his elbows dislocated they call the
ambulance and by the time the ambulance
got there the other team just forfeited
the game
that was okay I'm done I'm gonna be a
rock star now now it's now it's 100 rock
star at first it was whichever one hits
first I was so confident I was gonna
play football that when that uh rival
League the usfl remember that one that
was two there was NFL and usfo yeah we
had a Baltimore team the Stars yeah yeah
and uh there was a New Jersey generals
Chicago Bliss Trump was part of that was
he okay I saw like 30 for 30 and they
said that he he was trying to buy a team
or had something to do with that yeah
yeah so um I was so confident when
people would say would you play for the
usfl or you're only going to play in the
NFL I'm like you know what whoever pays
you know
it depends on the contract brother
all right so yeah we have a lot you're
gonna have to come back and do another
episode with me
um I want to talk about you being a dad
now because you grew up without your
father you grow up under the roof of an
abusive stepfather who's also your
brother and your sister's [ __ ] dad
so how many kids do you have you said
you have a son right yes just one just
one kid all right and what and how are
you as a dad like do you are you honest
with them about your upbringing and uh
um you know my dad
he was never around uh like he would
come by take us to the movies I went to
work with him one day he was a truck
driver so when he would whenever he
would pass through Orange County from LA
to go to San Diego he would check to see
what my mom was doing or something you
know what I mean and my mom was in love
with him my mom even to this day she's
like man I should have stayed with your
dad is that right yeah she just has a
thing for my dad and then I he my dad
comes by when I was 14 out of the blue
uh just to drop in and see what my mom's
doing give me some money I'm 14 years
old and when he dropped by unannounced
uh uh my mom's roommate I thought it was
her boyfriend but it was my mom's
roommate she was living with a girl
named Letty uh and me and my brother
were in one room my mom and her friend
who who just got divorced for living in
another room her boyfriend was eating
breakfast downstairs with me so my dad
walks in and my mom's making the
breakfast but it's her friend's
boyfriend my dad walks in
hey what are you doing here he goes uh
let's go get something she grabs and
goes let's go get something to eat he
takes me to eight salt fish and chips
and he tells me this is the last time
I'm gonna see you
I said like I didn't give a [ __ ] because
he wasn't around anyways he never told
me he loved me or nothing like that he
never said I love you son he would just
come around give me you know see if he
could hang on a mom that's what he
didn't want to get to know me and [ __ ]
so he said this is the last time I get
to see it's obvious that your mom is uh
moving on you know he had it all wrong
that wasn't even her boyfriend I thought
it was when I when I remembered it I
thought it was you know even if it was
my mom's boyfriend you know he um
the exact same thing would have happened
uh he decides to
tell me that he's not going to come
around no more he doesn't want to
interfere with uh my mom and her
relationships so he he gives me a um
like it's like death bed confessional
type [ __ ] he goes two things two things
I remember he told me because it's like
the last let me give you some like
advice and is this the last time you saw
him no okay it was for 14 years 14 years
but um he said when you get married
make sure your wife is at least 15 years
younger than you
because women age quick they age faster
than men he told me that I was like like
before I leave before I leave you
forever
maybe some a couple uh bits of advice
and then the other one was
always be nice to kids because they grow
up real quick
and uh then he was gone so then I didn't
see him from 14 to 27. so between 14 and
27 it was just all music it was just
like I'm trying to be in a like football
ain't happening so I went all in on
music
moved to Hollywood with my buddy James
and John to conquer the music business
when I was 21 I lived in Hollywood since
21.
um 24 25 still trying to make it working
check cashing just working odd jobs
um started working at a strip club after
check cashing became a d strip club DJ
um while I was in Hollywood trying to
make uh trying to get a record deal now
it's 25 and I like I didn't think I
would ever see my dad again like I
hadn't seen him since I was 14 now 26. I
still haven't seen him I would have
dreams that you know I'd see him when I
wake up I'm like like [ __ ] them you know
whatever he didn't give a [ __ ] about me
so [ __ ] him but I always had him on on
my mind and then out of the blue I'm 27
and my aunt calls me and she goes your
dad's like your grandma house
come on now my oh
[ __ ]
so I drive down to Orange County from
Hollywood and I know you're coming yeah
he knows so my mom is going to meet us
there we're all going to my grandma's
house
and uh you know he was he was tight with
my grandfather but he had disappeared
for so long so now he's there and my
ants like
Dad's here come on man
so the whole drive I'm like I'm just
gonna let bicons become bygones I'm just
gonna be cool I'm not gonna give him any
attitude [ __ ] it he's back I'm gonna I
just want to get to know him you know I
want to you know get to know my dad oh
yeah I'm not gonna I'm not gonna give
him any [ __ ] I'm just gonna be totally
[ __ ] cool so I get to my grandma's
totally cool we're all there we're just
shooting the [ __ ] my mom's there my
mom's all happy like I said my mom
always had a thing for him even to this
day she's still uh she'll still I should
have stayed with your dad he was so good
to me I'm like really he was married
with five kids
it gets worse though it gets worse so
she uh so um we're like hey let's go to
let's go get something to eat so we go
to Black Angus on on Tustin
um
and we're all it's me my mom and my and
my uh Dad we're a [ __ ] damn I thought
[ __ ] was dead man be like [ __ ]
haven't heard from him in Forever
bam never expected this like 14 years
later
something like that from 14 to 27 13
years and uh now I'm like he's here he's
like right in front of me holy [ __ ] God
damn it he's right in front of me holy
[ __ ] and I'm telling him that you know
I'm you know I'm in Hollywood I'm trying
to get a record deal it's you know got
some producers we're gonna make it work
we're gonna blow up
[ __ ] okay and then I decided um you know
I just wanted to ask him
why why now why'd you come by now what
was what were you thinking and um
the right answer would have been I just
I wanted to see uh what you were up to
it's been so long I just wanted to see
how you how you developed and man you
know I think about you even though I
wasn't around you know
um but he didn't say that [ __ ] he said I
was passing through town I'm doing some
deliveries I wanted to see if your
grandpa was still cool with me
and I was just like the
do you want to see if my grandpa still
coach you huh and then right there I'm
like I'm never gonna see this
[ __ ] ever again right there I'm
like I got my mom's over here right here
she's begging for my time and I'm always
telling her I don't have you know I'm
dizzy I'm busy and now I'm trying to
spend time with this [ __ ] if I'm
gonna give anybody my time it's going to
be my mom yeah at that point and I just
like I don't give a [ __ ] what he said at
that point I'm like you're dead to me
I'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and have you seen him ever since
this is what happened he goes hey your
step your half brothers and sisters they
want to meet you can I give them your
number I said yeah and give him my
number so they he he um gave them my
number
and uh then he called me and left a
message on a boy on voicemail back then
um
and said hey let's go get some lunch
and uh
how you know what I was thinking I was
thinking I want to be saying that
because I DJ at a strip club because
that's what I was doing at that time
three months ago season like does he
want to get something you want to use me
for some [ __ ]
that's what I was thinking that's the
first thing I don't wave you um
that I'm working at a strip club yeah DJ
him so um never responded I just let it
go I said [ __ ] I'm done
it's good you set a boundary yeah I'm
like I don't need that [ __ ] I'm good I'm
fine but his uh my half-sister and
brother
or they got a hold of me and we went The
Old Spaghetti Factory on Sunset and just
and just hung out and I met him
and my sister goes
you know how many kids your dad have
as a sex
[ __ ] try 19. no I said 19. he's got 19
19 did he was spraying everywhere he's a
truck driver getting everyone pregnant
everywhere 19.
it made me feel good yeah because before
I was like how could he not care about
me like it's possible to have a kid and
not give a [ __ ] about them never he
never told me he loved me and like is I
was afraid to have kids because I
thought I'm gonna be like that right and
if I like
my worst nightmare is that my kid feels
about me the way I feel about my dad
that would like make me want to kill
myself yeah you know so
my 19th so I thought oh no wonder no
wonder he doesn't give a [ __ ] about me
there's too many kids you can't give a
[ __ ] about all of them so I'm like damn
he had a bunch of them I was just one of
a bunch so it made me feel better about
myself yeah I hear you on that I felt a
little better you know and
and then uh I never saw how many of them
have you met
two just and then another one
um uh we DM each other on Instagram
every now and now and then Sylvia uh but
I never really um you know because I got
my my uh brother and sister that I grew
up with and I I don't barely give them
any time like if I'm gonna if I'm gonna
give someone time I'm gonna give someone
time that I grew up with and was there
for me you know what I mean and uh and
not that I don't want to meet my other I
got a lot of half brothers and half
sisters all over the place it's not that
I don't want to meet them it's just that
um
you know I'm a son of my own now I got
I'm so goddamn busy it's hard to start
like new relationships yeah it's very
hard it's very it's very hard and um you
know
I should be spending more time with my
sister and my brother and you know so
there's that too
um isn't it a while because for me my
mom was your dad
blows me away that I'm the same way with
my daughter so we're about the same age
when we had kids so I'm about two I'm
three years behind you yeah and your
son's 10. I was 40 when I had yeah 41. I
was 42 and I had one yeah so I'm right
there with you and
um yeah it blows me away though I mean
every time I look at I'm like how the
[ __ ] could you hate your own kid yeah
how could you not want to see your own
yeah yeah you didn't have 19 of them
yeah but you know what but then you have
to draw on those terrible times so you
can say I want to correct that break
that cycle I don't want to be like my
dad well I found out
the second he was born that I wasn't
like my dad
and I tell my son I love him every day
multiple times every time I see him
he just he just bows down and I kiss him
on the top of the head and just give him
like 25 kisses before he goes to sleep
tell him I love him multiple times and
well it's like it gets to a point where
it's goofy it's like super goofy like
when I'm ready to go to work give him
his kisses and tell him I love him and I
love you he goes I love you and then as
I walk away I love you I love you I love
you until we can't hear each other and
I'm up the stairs
it's like Goofy and it's like but I
don't give a [ __ ] how goofy that is I'll
tell him I love you all day every day
I'm just so stoked that I'm not like my
dad oh my God I'm not trying to uh not
be like him I'm not like him right I I
love my my son is everything to me yeah
my son is everything he's my my whole
life revolves around him and
um you know trying to
bring them up um
as best I could you know I'm trying you
know I'm not perfect but I you know I'm
doing my best and I love the dad I love
being a father you know when you when
you have a kid
like every year you get older
sucks right you know 52 I'm like damn 53
and then 54 and 54 like but every year
you you you get older your son gets
older too or your kids get older so you
get to experience them at that age and
then like now I'm 53 but he's gonna be
11 now 54 but I get him at 12. so
um you do live through your kids like
yeah I do like I'm like like I do I mean
I'm I don't know if you if I'd say I'd
live through them vicariously but that's
my flesh right there like you know the
the second he was born you know had
something to die for something he didn't
know me from hole in the wall for the
first year he didn't know he knew his
mommy he knew that titty he knew that
titty real but he don't know his dad
like when you're like
two months you know who your father is
but it's it's um it's um
mind-boggling How uh
quickly you would give your life for him
like if someone said you and your son
boom right now I'm like [ __ ] of course
me like like not even there isn't even a
thought it's crazy how there's
living with um
someone you would die for is important
that's super important when you're
living and you have no one that you
would die for like like you would just
pick them over you anytime if there was
like a choice of death
I think
um
[Music]
I think you're not living to your full
potential I mean I I'm not talking [ __ ]
on people that don't have kids but um
um unless you're a shitty person if you
have a kid
just it you realize like damn I didn't
know I could love this much I didn't
know I love can get that high I always
thought you know love was right here
yeah I could love this I could love that
and I love my dog and I love my cat but
when you have a kid you're like oh damn
you just turbocharger of love
unconditionally you know um it's um
it's a lot scarier
uh when you have someone you would die
for You Know You're vulnerable you know
someone there's someone that could uh
you know say anything happen to them it
would just destroy you you know what I
mean that's that's the there's a we like
the Kryptonite the weakness you know
um you know that's that's the downside
but um
it wouldn't
be so amazing if there wasn't that you
know if there wasn't that like yeah
You're vulnerable but it's
the meaning of life like you were you
were someone's kid like to not have I
mean people that are I know have friends
that are
they're um
they love their animals and their pets
to death and but they don't want a kid
they're thinking that is enough I got a
dog and I got a cat and that's enough
but
um anybody that loves animals that much
for sure are gonna be great parents I
agree with that that's the one thing
like because uh I do have love in you
it's not about what you're loving it
exists in you yeah if you love your dog
like it's like it's your best friend or
it's like a part of you uh if you had a
kid whoa you would be a great man I
agree that's a good sign anybody it's
good with pets and good with animals
they're gonna make great parents you're
gonna be a great mom Kirsten for sure
see what all right first of all this has
been a fantastic [ __ ] episode thank
you I apprecially got to learn a lot
about you
um now I mentioned to you before off
Mike um I would ask you advice you'd
give to your 16 year old self so after
everything we've talked about here today
what would you tell 16 year old Eddie
Bravo ah
um if that was like because Here Comes
Your Son six years yeah if that was
reality if I really could
tell my 16 year old self if I give my to
my advice I if that was for real I
wouldn't say [ __ ] to him because I
wouldn't change anything for the world
because if anything got altered in my
life
I probably wouldn't have my son and uh I
wouldn't take that chance like if I gave
some advice that might just lead him a
whole different way maybe a more
successful way or whatever but then that
means my son doesn't exist so if if that
was reality yes like you know for a joke
as a joke no not a joke it's for real
okay for real one station just stay this
course that's that's great advice yeah
that is the advice
um for a joke I would say dude AIDS is
fake you don't have to wear condoms
throw that rubber away
or
just remember after you have raw sex
take a piss right afterwards
great advice trust me
um One More Time promote everything
you'd like please
look into it with Eddie Bravo on rockfin
um the free episodes are available on
iTunes as well and rockfin
um go to samtripley.com for uh the
latest in tin foil hat comedy shows that
I do with them it's me and Sam and all
the infos on Sam's website he's the the
main dude I just opened for him
and what else what else uh hook thieves
is um uh the my current music project
and we're about to drop an album it's a
it's a parody Comedy album uh
uh acoustic piano
um just goofy ass [ __ ] a lot of um
scam demic material in there uh that's
how the whole album came came along was
during the scandemic man I just spent a
lot of [ __ ] time writing music and
writing just stupid lyrics about the
stupid [ __ ] we're going through
um
that's coming out uh what else I guess
that's it what do you want IG like
what's your
at Eddie Bravo 10p 10 10 uh at Eddie
Bravo is not me and at Eddie Bravo 10 is
not me he's got a it's you gotta put the
10p there's imposters out there I know
it
brother thank you thank you come on this
is a great episode uh as always Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all social
media we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]